we're here
we're outside the birds are chirping a
lot of aggressive parakeet noises yeah
and at some point there's a lake not far
away that these geese might fly over to
and they do a real honk job
what
[Music]
i don't know it just came out it sounded
so funny when i said it
and hj i'd like to um
that's the new hj
oh
i'm going to um explain
to the list here yeah
that matt and sona have been drinking
what have you guys been drinking we're
drinking the chilled chum yeah we'll
explain what's in it it's bourbon
pomegranate juice lemon and muddled
strawberry right so they did that that's
good and then they huffed gasoline yeah
siphoned it out of our cup
i've not had as much um i'm trying to
keep an even keel
but you just broke yourself up with hunk
job
so that's pretty good yeah it's you know
what it holds up when i hear you say it
it's still pretty good yeah i like it
sun is way out of control so now you're
gonna be okay because you probably your
tolerance is way down because you've had
children
and been breastfeeding and you weren't
drinking from no i wasn't for over a
year i wasn't drinking and now i'll have
this and then it's like party time right
let me know if you need a refresher
because we've got my lovely i need a
refresher sister-in-law on hand i need a
refresher okay
can we summon one of you guys to but you
know what maybe i should pace myself up
to you no it's funny it's funnier if you
don't yeah there's nothing less amusing
on a podcast than someone pacing
themselves
we've got people people are invested
right now can i eat these strawberry
bits yeah yeah sure go go ahead
uh i'm gonna try and keep keep this boat
on course if i can thank you amanda
thanks amanda thank you very much amanda
you're living the life look at you here
you're king of the podcast world your
beautiful wife is bringing you a kooky
concoction of your own devising and
we're all huddled around this gorgeous
fire courtesy of the good people at solo
stove now that's a fine machine i'll say
that right there yeah yeah if i'm gonna
build a fire outside i want a solo stove
you know what i'm gonna stoke the fire
put in a little
draggy poo and i'm gonna give it a hulk
job
i know any case i was that's where i was
going
god i'm trapped here with these idiots
all right well that doesn't doesn't
matter
oh thank you oh my god amanda thank you
so much are you good cozy uh i'm really
good and it's conan oh okay i'm your
employer
okay
you're you're like the guy who has
dinner with his boss and then humiliates
himself and you're gonna listen
you're gonna listen to you're gonna
listen to this tomorrow and be like cozy
i called him
and amanda's gonna be saying what were
you doing it's true because you kept
saying hunk job
cozy today when i was like cleaning the
backyard and we had to kind of like
figure out who was going to watch glenn
at certain points and i was like but the
boss is coming over for dinner right i
used to love that i mean i grew up
watching bewit sitcoms like bewitched in
reruns and um that was this an old trope
as the boss is coming over and
everything's going to be perfect and
then of course the housewife always
ruins everything
and of course the boss or the new client
finds it delightful yeah and says i see
what you're doing this is a new ad
campaign
i love it you're you're a genius stevens
that's you you're the boss you're larry
tate i am larry tate how's this excuse i
am the larry tate of late night i'm the
larry tate of late night comics
that was always my larry tate was great
tell us more about larry tate yeah yeah
tell us what you liked about larry t
larry tate just had this like really
great way of commanding a scene
and he did
what did you like about his hair i liked
that his hair was uh i liked that like
natural highlights that he had when he
would you mean like blonde yeah like he
would have those natural blonde
highlights because he was from
california originally i don't know if
you knew about no i didn't know we
didn't we should find out the actor who
played larry yeah you could probably
look that up at some point
okay you're just out of control i can't
do this you can't
no larry tate was the guy who was uh
samantha's uh husbands
you know darren sierra uh his bo the
boss yeah do you two know any new people
no no i stopped learning not interesting
i stopped learning new things yeah in
1982. yeah um when oingo boingo came out
with their first hit i said
i'm good yep i'm gonna stick with
everything up until now when wilson
phillips dropped that first album i said
i'm done i don't need anything more i
can't get any better first of all oh
yours was you can't get any better but
you were you're not an oingo boy so hold
on yeah for one more day things are
gonna change things are gone your way
hold on for one more day
um i like the part where it gets the
drum goes
and it's almost like a i mean it wasn't
wrap yeah but it was it told you to wear
it down it was it was kind of a
breakdown
yeah
anyways so cool
[Laughter]